if there's anything you could say is a
true constant
in today's entertainment industry it's
this what the rock says
goes dwayne johnson's on-camera talents
and unshakable work ethic have turned
him into one of the biggest a-listers in
the world
in every sense of the word even though
hollywood's biggest name
has a few forgotten failures in his
resume the fact that johnson is able to
say that he's the wealthiest star in the
entire fast and furious franchise
more than makes up for the occasional
turkey and he wasn't even
part of the original squad thanks to
johnson's borderline superhuman
achievements in the movie business
and his impressive physique of course
fans have long been clamoring to see him
kick things up a notch and play an
actual superhero or as the case may be
super villain and sure enough johnson
has lately been getting the most ripped
he's ever been
in order to play black adam the
dangerous predecessor turned
nemesis of the superhero shazam and he's
not just showing up in a few scenes in
someone else's feature either
oh no johnson's black adam is getting
his very own movie
the black adam solo film has been in
development for a good while now
so it's been easy to assume that the
movie has been chugging along at
whatever pace
warner brothers and dc entertainment can
manage but it looks like that pace is
rapidly quickening
as the rock has just revealed something
big the first pages of the black adam
script
in a three-minute video clip on
instagram johnson showed his 225 million
plus followers his copy of the black
adam script
written by adam stekiel with fresh
revisions courtesy of the mauritanian
writers rory haynes
and saurabh noshovani regarding the
movie's impending shooting dates
johnson had this to say i mean i can't
believe we are at the finish line
uh with this thing and what a journey it
has been that journey
johnson is referencing has been a rocky
one indeed
as it seems to reference the fact that
black adam was supposed to debut
in theaters in december of this year
before it was pulled off the schedule
indefinitely due to the coronavirus
pandemic
so it feels good to be on the verge of
bringing black adam to life johnson
continued to explain how he's been
fine-tuning the script over the last few
months
placing bright yellow stickers on pages
where he wanted to leave notes
as part of his intensive tequila fueled
script study
to celebrate the impending start of
filming johnson led his audience in on
this particular night of script study
lifting the veil by showing off the very
first page
which reads well i'd love to wear a
rainbow every day
and tell the world that everything's
okay but i'll try to carry off a little
darkness on my back
till things are brighter i'm the man in
black fans of country legend
johnny cash will no doubt recognize this
as a slightly modified
quote from his signature song man in
black and johnson stated that the quote
is instrumental to the very essence of
black adam
it gives you guys an example
of who black adam is and who black adam
is to the world of the dc
universe beyond that though johnson had
something to say about the movie's place
in the world of blockbuster superhero
movies and that is the dc universe
but that also includes the marvel
superhero universe too
realizing that this remark might have
broken the internet even further
johnson was good enough to clarify now
look i'm not saying that there's going
to be a mashup i'm not saying that but
what i am saying is it doesn't matter to
me and it doesn't matter it's a black
adam you put them all on notice
understandably this sneak peek has got
fans
very excited indeed so excited in fact
that a good portion of the post's
comments are simply
various combinations of thumbs up fire
and heart emojis
as well as heartfelt shows of support
for example
one user simply wrote hyped while
another commented
always are rock meanwhile one
appreciative cash fan simply said
johnny cash baby so yeah not a bad
response so far
and it seems like the rock fans and dc
fans alike are hugely enthusiastic to
finally see johnson play black adam
and since the actor also revealed that
he'll start shooting the movie in about
three weeks
which should be sometime in april it
looks like the day the movie finally
drops is inching closer and closer
until then keep an eye out for the man
in black folks
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you